by popular demand it's John Carter
another movie where somebody goes to
Mars and yet another one they're
completely bombs everyone was talking
about this movie when it came out not
because everybody went to go see it but
because everybody didn't go see it this
was a big-budget movie and nobody had
any interest in and it's seen as one of
Disney's biggest bombs what I want to go
see it and honestly I don't think it was
that bad that's to say it's nothing
spectacular didn't change my life or
anything but as a dumb little adventure
goes about traveling to Mars and
fighting aliens and coming across new
creatures I thought it was fine
John Carter is a war veteran who finds
him so traveling all the way to Mars he
fights his gravity is different from
everyone else's so he finds he can
actually jump around like a superhero
leaping hundreds of feet in the air some
of the aliens see this as a threat the
one wave alone Dafoe fights in quite
interesting and decides to befriend him
he also comes across this friendly dog
type creature and of course a woman of
power so let's just take a guess and say
she's what a shot it turns out not only
does most of the plants see him as a
threat but there's also a war that's
brewing and it turns out he has to stop
it but he's tired of war and doesn't
want to get involved but through a
series of circumstances and attachment
to his friends he finds he has to get
involved some constant battles and big
effects and even a few funny moments
here and there John Carter may find he
cares a lot more than he thought he
would yeah that kind of gives you an
idea of what this movie's gonna be like
it's a b-movie and it is silly and it is
over-the-top but at the same time the
dedication a lot of these people have
particularly the actors I found myself
actually kind of getting invested nono
remind me of another Disney film that
didn't do so hot called the three
musketeers everyone kind of beats up on
it for all the cliches but the cliches I
kind of like maybe it's the nostalgia
and me maybe there's just a part of me
that kind of likes to see something
that's big and goofy but kind of
connects to the humanity that I like
connecting to and so much of that does
come from the characters it's not overly
dark but it's not too light either it
certainly has a lot of violence but
there's a lot of friendly moments as
well the parts between Carter and the
Willem Dafoe
alien is easily the best stuff you just
feel the connection between these two
they're both kind of outsiders but
they're not the typical oh you're a nerd
you're a dweeb outsider they both seen a
lot of rough stuff and they're both
trying to fight a big system and even
the connection between him and this
weird little dog is kind of charming I
don't know there's just something kind
of nice and friendly about it but it has
just enough action and sci-fi weirdness
that I actually thought it was
entertaining but what that's it is it
actually a good movie it depends on what
you're looking for if you're looking for
something really new with a lot of
twists and turns it doesn't have that
much I mean nobody's gonna get invested
in this like sale or the Rings or
something I also cared this is based on
an old book series and I guess according
to fans it doesn't really follow the
book series that well so again I might
not be the best person to talk about it
but that's a simple movie goer who is a
little interested in seeing a guy travel
to Mars and shoot up aliens I thought it
was okay it was visually interesting it
was creative with its ideas and it has
some likable characters I definitely say
if you're not familiar with the books
and you had any interest after watching
the trailer you probably think what I
thought of it if you have a free evening
or an afternoon and you just want pop in
some fun sci-fi nonsense I think this
does the job fine definitely better than
some other Mars related Disney films
take a look for yourself and find out